Hello!
Before this video begins, I wanted to remind you guys,
to check out originpc.com/pewdiepie, first link in the description.
Sign up to the giveaway, because I'm giving away a computer by Origin.
It's an incredible piece of machinery, it's been kissed by yours truly.
So I can approve that it's filled with love.
Check out my setup video as well, where I show off my Origin PC computer.
I love this thing, I couldn't recommend it enough and I'm very proud to be working with Origin. But that's it.
Enjoy the video (ok).
Anime Girl: Ma'am, look at me.
w h a t?  w h a t?
Anime Girl: Just look at me, look at me.
Pewds: Ok.
OH MY GOD *chuckle*
Anime Girl: H a H a H a
Anime Girl: I'm a god of this world.
Anime Girl: I can fly.
Okay well, don't worry about it. I can do the same.
God damn it.
w o a h
This is dope.
We got fireworks and sh- oh my god. Uh, that is bright.
Pewds: Hey, hey.
Arwis: hELLO HELLO!
Pewds: Ok, ok. Hey, have u seen the anime ba-
Arwis: HELLO!
Yes, yes. Have you seen the anime babes?
Arwis: Okay, let's go.
Pewds: Okay, let's... let's go.
Arwis: I am Ruther.
Pewds: You are a Ruther...? Great. I am-
Arwis: Yes.
Arwis: I am Youtube blogger.
Pewds: *chuckle* I am Youtube blogger too!
Pewds: Wha- what's your channel?
Arwis: Ok.
Pewds: Ok...
Arwis: My channel Arwis.
Pewds: Arwis? I'll check you out man.
Arwis: Yes.
*Poods looks up Arwis*
*RIP, there's no arwis, he doesn't know de wey*
Where the hell did he go? *laughs*
Hey, hey, hey, hey..
I know de wey
Come with me. Come with me, and I will show you, alright?
It's inside me, de wey is inside me.
Xenith: That's Futafuta alright? Back up. Alright?
Hey hey
Huh? What are you gonna do, man? Huh?
Xenith: Get out of my face, alright?
Uh, you get outta my face!
Xenith: My bones in you, bro.
Oh yeah.
Xenith: Hey, you like that?
No, I don't like that
Okay, go away from me.
Hey, hey, hey.
Hey, my boat is with food a food. I'm not you alright?
Xenith: Hey come here
Stay! Eh, eh!
Holy shit, I can control it?
Alright, what color do you guys want? I got this.
That's all I know to say.
Святой: [Russian]
No, no, no, Uganda.
Святой: [Spit]
Hey look at you, I'm one of em'.
I woke -
You.
No!
You want to die?
[Some Intense hissing]
Come here you cyka blyat, cyka blyat!
Святой: [Screaming]
Whoa!
Holy cow, what is that? Oh, my god.
Don't shoot, don't shoot. I am Ugandan. Please don't shoot
Pls dont shoot.
Святой: [Singing some of russian anthem]
N-no, what the hell? Shut up.
Святой: Pew pew pew pew
Святой: [Intense spitting]
Stop spitting on everything!
Hey! Hey! Hey! Can I go with you? Can I ride with you?
Hey, who said that?
OK, go.
Jesus
Does anyone want to touch? Touch my nipples?
Banana: I'll take you to my dungeon.
*Chuckles* Alright, Jesus.
Banana: I know de wey
Alright.
Banana: Let's go.
Why does it sound like it's about to climax?
AMAZING
WOW
Yes.
The hell happened to you?
You need help?
Gaepastore88: Hi.
I am the queen everybody! You are welcome.
Someone: Spit on the queen.
No, no, no, no! don't spit, don't spit.
No spitting. I will touch that- stop spitting!
I will bless each one if you to come forward. Yes, I will. Banana man, I dub you-
Bananaman: Thank You
I dub you -
Ugandan warrior
That's right. Come here. Come here, Kai.
Come here, come
Come here, Kai. I will bless you. I will bless you with my hands.
Kai, come here. Kai, kai. Listen to me. Come here and I will bless you.
*sings annoyingly*
*Knuckles from K​.​N​.​U​.​C​.​K​.​L​.​E​.​S. & Knuckles by Triple-Q plays*
Wow, you spin so graciously.
Hey, careful with those blades. You could cut someone. Is that Mario?
Something went wrong when they made this.
The game wasn't supposed to be like this.
(Jesus)
HUUUUUUUUH
God damn. I look good.
Hell yeah, men. I look so nice. *insert Sayori's voice*
OH MY GOD
This is the weirdest shit.
Are you Knuckles made out of Knuckleses?
No, I am.
Thank- thank you. I am one knuckles. And the other knuckles are just my dead children.
Also where's your second eye in your main thing?
Hey, *chuckles* don't worry about that.
I am just
Don't worry about the details
Okay, this is just how I was born
This is who I am,
Someone: Are you sure?
and please don't judge -
Listen, you're like an undead creature, alright?
I don't need your judgment.
from now on knuckles is running the bar. What can I get ya?
What do you want?
Someone: Can you get me every drink?
Every drink coming right up sir, there.
We got this one, we got this one, we got this one.
I hope you -
you're ready to pay up.
Someone 2: I don't think you know much about drinks.
Someone: I am, I am.
I know everything you need to know about drinks.
Someone 3: Shut up he's (?) like a profesional.
That's right. Thank you.
All right, what do you want? What do you want then?
Excuse me?
(?) alcohol, my dude.
Sir, sir, sir
Someone: Your body- your body is made up of like,
Someone: twenty of you.
Someone 2: Not okay-
It's my children, it's my children
Someone 2: Not okay. Not okay.
You can be my child too.
S 2: Not Okay.
S2: Not okay.
It's Okay.
S2:Not okay.
Stop poking me, stop poking me.
Hey, it is okay.
Its- Uh..
S2: Not okay
S3: What the f***? How many-
Yes one hundred percent okay.
S4: How many avatars are conjoined here?
That's my cousin Jerry, alright?
Be nice to him.
S2: Not okay.
Okay, 100%
Listen I'm blocking left and right, what up.
S2: Not okay.
S3: Not okay.
Okay, it's okay.
Okay, okay.
Hey, hey
Come with me.
Hey. Hey, be quiet.
Gimme: Pewdiepie, pewdiepie, pewdiepie!
Gimme: Pewdiepie, pewdiepie...
No...
No
No he's not stop following me, please.
Gimme: Pewdiepieee!
No, no, no, it's Ugandan warrior,
Gimme: Oh my god!
Big head: Could I Have a drink?
Yes.
All right, what do you want?
Please, behind the counter people. I'm trying to work here.
Hello, hey.
Hey, hey.
Hello.
Come here
Someone: No, don't do this.
Oh, you wanna say hi to tiny knuckles?
*Sayori voice* Hey, it's tiny knuckles. I wanna be a friend.
Someone 2: Hello.
*Sayori voice* Give tiny knuckles a little hug.
S3: He sounds familiar but I-
Hey, I'm a tiny knuckles
Don't you want a family
Tiny knuckles
S2: Why he is with -
Give tiny knuckles a kiss.
Come here.
Gimme a hug.
Oh my god.
What happened to you.
Tiny knuckles want a kiss.
S: Oh, very much love.
S: [Kiss]
OH, WOW.
Thank you.
All right, I'm gonna go find the way, but it's been great. Can't wait to find the way
Girl: Wow
Hey, baby, you come here often?
Girl: What is that? [Laughs]
What is -
Come up.
You want to say hi to -
Tiny Knuckles
Hellou, I'm tiny knuckles.
Wanna be my girlfriend?
Girl: [Laughs]
Be my girlfriend, I'm tiny knuckles, I'm looking for a girlfriend.
Hellou
I'm tiny knuckles.
Will you be my girlfriend?
Alright alright alright how about how about this one?
Why does sonic wear gloves?
Anyone?
Twitch: Whyyy?
Cuz his hands are cold
Okay, uhh-
If tails lost one of his tails where will he get a new one?
Girl: Where?
Casper: In motors.
Llokelf: GET THE FK OUT OF HERE
At the-
At the reTAILer, thank you, thank you, thank you
*Cheering*
Okay, that was it.
For today's episode of tiny knuckles. Leave a like if you enjoy watching and I see you next time.
Byeeeeeeeeee :3